GREAT TO SEE YOU, LAURA.
THANK YOU.
>>> ALSO DEVELOPING THIS HOUR, A
MAJOR NATIONAL TASK FORCE IS
PROPOSING RECOMMENDING AGAINST
TAKING A DAILY ASPIRIN TO CUT
THE RISK OF HEART DISEASE AND
STROKE IF YOU ARE OVER THE AGE
OF 60.
IT'S PART OF NEW RECOMMENDATIONS
ISSUED MOMENTS AGO BY THE GROUP
THAT ULTIMATELY REALLY SETS THE
NORMS FOR WHAT TREATMENTS AND
TESTS ARE IMPLEMENTED BY DOCTORS
AND CLINICIANS NATIONWIDE AND
ALSO TYPICALLY COVERED BY
INSURANCE.
JOINING ME NOW IS DR. CHEN WEN
SANG, A MEMBER OF THE U.S.
PREVENTATIVE SERVICES TASK
FORCE, THE TASK FORCE I'M
TALKING ABOUT ISSUING THIS
PROPOSED GUIDANCE.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
THIS POTENTIALLY IMPACTS
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE.
THE MOST RECENT NUMBER I SAW WAS
AT LEAST 29 MILLION AMERICANS
TAKE LOW-DOSE ASPIRIN EVERY DAY
FOR THIS VERY REASON, THIS
PREVENTION REASON.
AND PREVIOUSLY THIS WARNING OF
DO NOT DO THIS HAS BEEN FOR
PEOPLE AGE 70 PLUS.
NOW 60 PLUS.
WHY?
WHAT DID YOU ALL SEE?
>> OKAY.
THANKS FOR HAVING US HERE.
YOU KNOW, THIS IS SO IMPORTANT.
IT'S REALLY TALKING ABOUT THE
ROLE OF ASPIRIN IN PREVENTING
THAT FIRST HEART ATTACK OR
STROKE.
SO WE ACTUALLY STILL DO SEE SOME
BENEFITS FOR PEOPLE AGES 40 TO
59.
BUT THAT BENEFIT IS SMALLER.
YOU'RE RIGHT, YOU HAVE TO WEIGH
IT AGAINST THE RISK OR HARMS OF
BLEEDING FROM ASPIRIN.
FOR AGES 40 TO 59 WE RECOMMEND
THAT PEOPLE STILL CONSIDER
ASPIRIN BUT TALK ABOUT IT WITH
THEIR CLINICIAN FIRST TO MAKE
HURT IT'S THE RIGHT MATCH AND
THAT THE HARMS ARE NOT ALWAYS
LIKE THE BENEFITS.
FOR PEOPLE AGE 60 AND OLDER, WE
RECOMMEND AGAINST STARTING
ASPIRIN BECAUSE THE RISK OF
BLEEDING INCREASES WITH AGE, AND
STARTING AT AGE 60, THE HARMS
CANCEL OUT THE BENEFITS.
>> IF I'M -- JUST TO DIG INTO IT
BECAUSE THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE WATCHING WHO OBVIOUSLY
TAKE A DAILY DOSE AND EVERYONE'S
MEDICAL HISTORY IS THEIR OWN,
BUT IF I'M 63 YEARS OLD AND ON A
DAILY DOSE REGIMEN OF ASPIRIN
FOR PREVENTION, WHAT SHOULD I DO
TODAY, DOCTOR?
SHOULD I STOP?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
SO THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT TO
KNOW THAT THIS IS A
RECOMMENDATION ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT TO START ASPIRIN TO PREVENT
THE FIRST HEART ATTACK OR STROKE
FOR PEOPLE WHO AREN'T ACTUALLY
ON ASPIRIN YET.
IF SOMEBODY STARTED TAKING
ASPIRIN ALREADY OR IS ON ASPIRIN
BECAUSE THEY'VE HAD A HEART
ATTACK OR STROKE, WE DON'T WANT
THEM TO STOP.
THEY SHOULD TALK TO THEIR
CLINICIANS IF THEY HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT TO CONTINUE
ASPIRIN BUT DON'T STOP ON THEIR
OWN.
>> THIS COMES DOWN TO WEIGHING
BENEFITS AGAINST RISKS AS SO
MANY MEDICAL PROCEDURES AND
MEDICINES ARE, THAT'S WHAT YOU
HAVE TO WEIGH.
WHAT ARE YOU SEEING IN TERMS OF
THE RISKS THAT GOT YOU ALL TO A
PLACE OF CHANGING THESE
GUIDELINES?
>> WELL, ASPIRIN IS USED SAFELY
BY MILLIONS OF PEOPLE, BUT THERE
IS THE POTENTIAL RISK OF
BLEEDING SO IF SOMEBODY HAS
ISSUES OF STOMACH ULCERS OR
BLEEDING IN THE BRAIN OR ON
BLOOD THINNERS, OTHER HEALTH
CONDITIONS, TOO, THERE
DEFINITELY CAN BE MORE RISK.
WE WANT PEOPLE TO BE AWARE OF
THAT.
THERE'S ALSO THE POTENTIAL
BENEFITS SO THE BENEFITS ARE
SMALLER NOW TO START ASPIRIN TO
PREVENT THE FIRST HEART ATTACK
OR STROKE ARE STILL THERE.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE
TO KNOW TO TALK TO THEIR
CLINICIANS.
SO FIND OUT, ONE, ARE THEY AT
INCREASED RISK FOR HEART ATTACK
OR STROKE, AND TWO, WHETHER OR
NOT ASPIRIN'S BENEFITS OUTWEIGH
THE RISKS.
>> THIS IS DRAFT GUIDANCE, NOT
THE FINAL WORD IF YOU WILL.
DO YOU BELIEVE THIS WILL BE THE
FINAL WORD?
IS THERE ROOM FOR MANEUVERING?
>> WELL, THE TASK FORCE ALWAYS
PUTS OUT A DRAFT FIRST.
THIS IS A TIME WHEN WE LOOK FOR
INPUT FROM THE PUBLIC.
SO ORGANIZATIONS AND
INDIVIDUALS, WE TAKE EVERY
SINGLE COMMENT INTO ACCOUNT, SO
OFTEN THEY ARE SIMILAR.
WE ALSO TAKE INTO -- WE ALSO
CONSIDER SERIOUSLY THE COMMENTS
THAT COME IN.
>> DOCTOR THANKS YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME.
THIS IS IMPORTANT FOR SO MANY
AMERICANS, MILLIONS OF PEOPL